Our degrees of freedom are the sample size minus one plus the other sample size
minus one. Or we can just add them and then subtract two. So we get the degrees
of freedom is 16 in this case. Let's bring up our t table. When the degrees of
freedom is 16, and we have 0.025 in each tail, since we're doing a two-tailed
test at alpha equals 0.05. Then we get that the t critical value is 2.12. Since
our t statistic is less than the t critical value, that means it falls in the
middle of the distribution. 0.96 is maybe about here, whereas the t critical
value is out here. Therefore we'll accept Ho. Based on our samples, there's no
significant deviance that we would predict between the number of pairs of shoes
owned by males and females.